Mrs Beatty Beatty this is [ __ ] Mrs
beat it was great he [ __ ] beat me off
you know what I'm saying oh that would
be good so motive dude yeah yeah it's
that would be so cold-busted man yeah
it's true
I don't like when hair peeks out of the
Hat that's why it's fine but if it's
like that like like an actual garden
growing under his hat take it off it's
actually never it looks like Chia Pet
like he just [ __ ] puts the hat on and
then smears that [ __ ] stuff and then
Waters it and then and then the Hat
stays there and it grows out a little
bit like this is the time lapse like
that right but he's trying to also hide
his Chia Pet because it's poking out
from underneath right also pubes
pubes for sure 100 cubes on his head
yeah like there should be a dick on his
forehead yeah and there is and that's
why he's wearing a hacking he's hiding
it 100 all right cool and so he figures
out so let's do that
actually um I've been for a long time
Matt obviously got to you a little late
in the game Chris been a long time fan
of you for a long [ __ ] time through
thick and thin baby
so I need some advice
so my name is River and that's pretty
different nickname at least around here
you know like I'm thankful for it my
whole life I'm 24. I have dealt with uh
you know like the jokes on my name so
um which is cool like I don't care
because
kindergarten you know
um of course words that they use like
you know Lake ocean all that good [ __ ]
so I messed with this girl on a dating
app the other night I know stupid
shouldn't be all night and she said nice
to meet you Pond and I go oh nice
pretty big talk from somebody with a
normal name what's your name was Shelby
good millions of them and so she uh then
she responded back with wow are you
victim blaming it's not my fault that my
parents name me that and I said no it's
not victim blaming if I'm saying it in a
way of I I know it's not your fault but
you have a normal last name so know your
normal ass name place in life you know
so okay I'm not asking on I'm not asking
advice on how to deal with that I just
want funnier ways to respond back to
people that give me those kindergarten
uh nicknames like you know just the ones
that are just so on the nose and easy to
grab for it's a good question but uh
yeah thanks guys dude I think you should
say first of all I think he dealt with
it really well he did but he should say
actually that's funny because I wish we
were near a body of water so I could
drown you right now you know and kill
you in a river or anywhere or if they
say hi Pond you say interesting I wish
we were near a pond it's funny you bring
that up because I would love to drown
you
yeah for so long yeah
yeah and then well no it's on social
media what you what you but yeah oh
right actually what you're saying no but
what you should do is honestly
right
all of the things that people say all
the time on cards okay and always have
them with you good and then you show
them and then when they when they say
one just go like this
yep yep yep
pick it out and go like this
it says do you know how many times
someone has called me Pond they would
feel
that would be good so molded dude yeah
yeah it's that would be so cold-busted
man yeah it's true that would be so
moted but also when you start like start
with a number that's already high don't
start at one because then when you pull
it out like don't start from scratch
when you make that list because then
when somebody does it and you're like
you know how many times people have
called me Pond and then they read it and
then it says like two no no no but just
no but just say something that people
often say to me is oh so there's no
counter I'll hand it to it right okay
yeah it would be so molded yeah what is
moded combusted oh call busted okay one
time when um
um one time when I was in second grade
uh
Mrs Beatty I I remember her yeah I had
her she was a frumpy fat one nope oh
then I don't know her don't okay so now
that was Miss banaxis okay but no but so
now you're being worse than I was in the
beginning I was just like calling it
back okay but that's fine but maybe
they're dead now who's Mrs Beatty Mrs
Beatty Beatty this is [ __ ] Mrs Beatty
was great he [ __ ] beat me off you
know what I'm saying no nope absolutely
not man okay okay okay
wonderful woman oh okay second grade
teacher and I was yeah I didn't have her
I had Miss Caldwell
I remember her match venon had her she
was pretty oh maybe it's not she
probably got hit on she was really old
right Mrs Caldwell now she was very
young oh damn I I don't know okay so
anyway um
Rasheed I remember Rasheed he was pretty
funny yeah yeah he was [ __ ] funny I
wonder what he's doing now
um he was saying something to miss beat
him Miss Beatty was like Rasheed no hold
on a second and hold on a second and and
Rasheed said oh that's called busted and
then miss Beatty said Rasheed if you
don't get out of my face I'm gonna go
bust it all over you whoa yeah dude and
it was so hilarious dude I laughed so
hard as you could imagine I mean even in
second grade he knew it was funny oh me
yeah I had never heard kobasa before in
my life so I was laughing I was having a
conniption thing I mean man it was so
funny oh baby that's called busted
Racine if you don't get it in my face
I'm gonna go bust it all over the place
so she was she's gonna go bust it so
that would be a version of clapping back
not the best idea right exactly because
she because Rasheed could have went
right to the and she said the teacher
said but she was gonna bust on my face
then she's gone forever Witnesses I was
a witness so I would have been like she
didn't actually say that okay but she
did say that she didn't know all over
the place called busted all over the
place get caught doing something you
shouldn't while you're convicted guilty
of
um cold
it yeah they used it differently though
back then kobusted meant like [ __ ] up
not that wait wait hold up deliver
insulted that's what it was delivered
insult attempt to highlight inadequacy
I'm trying to raise money for college
your mom goes to college did that's what
it was yeah right okay yeah hell yeah
dude
[Music]